[Music]
the critics just been sitting there
brain-dead for a couple minutes
you know you're okay yes so if I'll
start I'll just read the Jones because
please okay so so you already look you
know a little knowing like yeah after
that's good okay because some of this
yard my data Hey look just because it is
a control panel to shift his thoughts
while looking through a circular screen
envision doesn't mean we stole anything
you know yeah right in fact I smell spit
up movie we do an another original
Disney classic I call it Kimba the White
Knight that never went to court we're
mostly in the clear on that one yeah let
me know how that frozen lawsuit works
out uh yeah we might be in trouble for
that one good uh when he goes oh yeah do
I got yeah that's good if I could just
do that reaction with this we're only
going to do what we're gonna do we do
the straight-up shots first okay so that
means that in the Shou you're looking
for pretty much and you're looking at
the big screen there so not you get the
camera correct
yeah you're more looking up at the
screen like they did in the movie and
with the layout is gonna be you are all
the way see you were all the way on this
side so you can stay there but everybody
is over here so I probably should be
kind of just a little bit of extreme
hunger yeah you could be straight on
because you're all you know looking
straight up and everything so but if you
ever gonna turn in and we talk to
someone it is always so what I'm gonna
do I'm just gonna read them all
all right trip he loved the movie but he
said it was like urban said oh please
nobody ever remembers that I did
definitely try your best to protect
I'll write repeal of the movie well he
said it was like Herman's head
oh please nobody even remembers that I
miss the other brother good if you can
just a touch louder I think it'll pick
up okay all right quite under set all
right true you loved the movie but he
said it was like Herman's head
oh please nobody even remembers that yes
say hi to everybody
oh yeah all right right right yes
follow the light is it okay if Jim puts
like some eyebrows and maybe like let's
go so it's up to you if you want to
watch this film for a bit or if now you
can just hang out there it's totally a
demon it's probably gonna give the head
so now it's probably gonna be really
boring because this you like everyone
has to shoot their scene separately so I
can color correct to make them glow and
stuff like that I included you so it's
probably like again they're gonna say a
line say it again I say it again okay
now I'm gonna say like 10 minutes might
be super exciting but you're more than
welcome to watch yeah watch the magic
happen
yes let's watch this magic Magic the
Gathering
oh you mean like this subconscious
that's represented that's a very scary
abyss Beauty which we were resented by
the way as a dark screen which we
represent by the way as a dark gray
scary of is yeah yeah and you just
looked like you still example just sir
like you know just are like you know
yeah okay my looking up here goes yes
okay let's get this in here okay okay
this fear my sorry mr. ding let's not
give in to fear fear is the mind killer
says oh it was supposed to be Jim J Ross
but Jim decided that he's done was we
told Jim he had to shave and his exact
response was uh yeah fuck you guys yeah
they're just like you know I think you
should play fear and it was just like no
offense but yeah it's actually won an
Emmy same way stick I'll see you clearly
now is the time to tell them we settled
on Tamra as we have no one else and
today's trying to basket just get a
chambers enemies just go thanks to
otherwise like Rachel left okay get a
roommate no we don't like to read or we
dress guy he's a drag all the time
anyway so nothing isn't that right
Malcolm don't worry
all we're saying is you do have a pretty
mouth okay I knew it quite a while have
you here I watched you some of the gifts
whoa that is crazy
but that's not all this is nuts
over here and these are made for you
know you guys so I mean you can go ahead
and like you know take them and stuff
like that someone made these three
drawings of us they're like bookmarks
they'd be home that is fantastic
look at that detail you drew me so
skinny Thanks pretty like you may look a
little chubby in these though these are
just like drooling over something after
did Rob see these I don't know if he's
no I don't find it yeah it's adorable
oh yeah yes that sneer is perfect
I guess you know what it makes me look
really older because of the feathers
here so it looks like I got a full beard
that's on the back I've got a little
sparkle I'm not chicken we'll just
pigeons in general I mean those look
like human those three not a man you're
a chicken well it's mad with you you
wear disguised to look like human but
you're not a man you're a chicken
Animaniacs 'they are adorable
then rub comes in to make everything
right add another one to the collection
here as explained in the well before
started recording so stall to kitten
friend and fan of mine make this for
Doug that's actually their character
dressed as the nostalgia critic or
rather the nostalgia kitten so it's
pretty cool that's so badass this one
was done by Jasper otherwise known as
Eric Rosengarten very good artist very
very good person so bad I saw this movie
a long time ago and actually kind of
liked it liked the animation but there
isn't a whole lot else I remembered from
it yes name I don't really remember too
much about this movie everything yeah
Chris Rock was like an amoeba or
something
I thought that was actually kind of
funny and I kind of liked how they did
like those live-action animation and
seeing the inside of Bill Murray's body
oh yeah yeah I forgot it was his body
yeah but I mean obviously there's
something really bad about it for Walker
to review and so yeah we'll find out
what it is in the review yeah although
this will be up it how long after the
review is post it's but congrats man
Congrats thank you I appreciate it
well you well you're welcome now say it
in the Chris Rock impression I mean I
appreciate it I mean it's just it's an
honor to be on the Nostalgia Critic I
mean this dude doing it he's killing it
and I'm just blessed to be here man let
him see oh he's maybe being inside his
body I'm constantly at the concept of
severing that button down I wish that
guy would calm down but why haven't you
why haven't you slam that button down
it's him it's him his insides aren't you
inside I'm actually inside section it's
the proud system and they're Taylor or
he has filming Stiller II finished
go get water
two people have to guess
Porter life-giving wouldn't water nectar
of the gods take one step in I'm pissed
off that's what I am so yeah so maybe
two about yeah yes okay yeah no oh
you're acting all right oh yeah nobody's
ever done it like this before what
you're poaching are you I'm pissed off
that's what I am hey that's my job buddy
yeah a job you all stole from me
osmosis jones oh great another word
shamsky fanboy wanna jump
osmosis jones not Jupiter Josie b13 oh
yeah nobody's ever done this before
that's what I am hey that's my job buddy
yeah a job you all stole from me
osmosis jones create another Chesky
fanboy not joke what a Jones
osmosis jones okay so the next
here the same spot so wait you're saying
we ripped you off if the father related
offense anyone's gonna watch this
revealing who are all these goofy yeah
exactly
it's like these fantastic new actors
with Chris and Taylor okay
wait you're saying we ripped you off if
the body related pun vets hey we're one
of the most brilliantly written films of
all time and you you're just a crisp are
we moving yeah that's right you ripped
out the people that make Jim Carrey a
male cougar wait you're saying me rip
you off if the body related pun fits
hey we're one of those brilliantly
written films of all time and you you're
just a Harvey Brothers movie yeah that's
right you ripped off the people that
make Jim Carrey a male toga missed in
all over here yes like unbelievable
impression okay so this is only audio
maza let's take a look at osmosis jones
and you say it's a the prequels inside
out you just hear a pow you go out so
you could just say it right to the mic
cause it's only audio all right let's
take a look at osmosis jones the prequel
the inside out let's find out with us
Moses Jones the prequel the inside out
oh what a wonderful okay
so cool so Chris yeah no no I haven't
gone yet oh you have been filming Chris
like that when she's not in fact I smell
a spinoff with you and another original
Disney classic I call it yes you got a
record that but there's no lines or
anything you just the impression has
left an impression
okay right go ahead and maybe we just
plug our subconscious which we represent
by the way as a dark gray scary of this
oh you mean like this subconscious
represented as a dark gray skin real
piss can I say that curse word now uh
yeah wait for me to cue ball
okay go ahead have a look again can I
say that curse word now it's like
Inception I can see you twice scepters
quick you're in the you're in the tank
and you have insurance I love James okay
which we represent by the way as a dark
gray scary of this oh you mean like this
okay just this represented as a dark
grey scaling of this can I say that so
what well we're doing something to look
at
and in that scene he actually said this
one thing a little me too oh can I see
that's weird and just keep your arms to
the side too
I don't mean you can do this but but
yeah don't don't raise them look can I
see that swear word now looking at the
screen doesn't say the screen you just
look super pissed off so you're just
like you know you can sort have your
hands on the side your minutes something
like that yeah that's good and then when
he starts talking you just sort of bring
your hands down look at him
and one of the lines they say is that
you know you're also far away from the
control panel and you slowly lift your
right hand what's that have to do with
any of you touch it yeah so but with
this I'm just gonna give you you know
the mark so you don't start off looking
angry I'll say turn you turn hand slowly
lift up and down okay so I gotta thought
you're gonna slap him
get more like know with your elbows down
like that more variables like I'm
covering my ears Oh more like yeah there
you go
watch Lord oh damn perfect really good
that tell us the wood you are going to
your body is gonna base this smells like
environmentally friendly my father clue
jinkies let's search for clues yeah for
the alien is that what she says yes okay
uh he says let's split up
he's almost lit up yeah he's like let's
split up yeah for some reason so pretty
much everyone do you know sadness is
still here and joy now Chris Rock is
going to be so what's gonna happen is
when I say action you're gonna turn and
look right at him you can read these
lines nobody's ever done like that
before
which motion are you I'm pissed off
that's what I am
hey that's my job buddy yeah I tell all
of you stole from me awesome Moses Jones
and I will just jump - hey we're one of
the most brilliantly written films of
all time and you you're just so far they
brothers book so no lines just reacting
to everybody and I don't think sadness
has any lines in this a well I mean
that's so yeah so everything you're
reacting to is either to your right or
you're just reacting to what emotion are
you I'm pissed off that's what I am hey
that's my job buddy
oh yeah a great job you stole from me
osmosis jumps hey we're one of the most
brilliantly written films of all time
and you just a farming products movie
okay well that's a wrap yeah very very
happy I'm gonna just collapse I had to
it what I'm really hoping it's because
it was getting really bad well shooting
my portion so I'm really hoping like the
footage I don't have like teary eyes and
like you know lines under my eyes and
I'm not super self just like I hope it
doesn't come off oh that was clever he's
doing us Moses gels and they just make
it look like he was dying so it's method
acting yeah
all right let's do green yes the green
great job oh boy
[Music]